best way to oppose fake news is for
people to watch Outlets like MSNBC where
you report real news all the time
people I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it is January 17 2023 we are live
streaming as always on Rumble and
YouTube If you have not subscribed at
rumble.com Reuben report would you go
ahead and do that uh things are looking
good across the board on the show our
numbers have just been phenomenal lately
I think that's a reflection of trying to
tell the truth around here and you guys
getting more engaged and more involved
in sharing the videos and all that good
stuff so we appreciate that and as
always we do a post game show where you
can correct me question me throw
thoughts at me and much more at
reubenreport.locals.com I think today
is going to be our biggest show ever I
have more paper than I think I've ever
had in my hand right now and you may be
looking at this card it's not a lot of
paper and you know I know these days if
you don't have a lot of something it's
okay automatically right Joe Biden it's
only a small amount of documents this
may seem like a small amount of
documents to you but I'd say this about
15 pages normally we do the show in
about seven pages we have a jam packed
information Laden show using multimedia
I'm talking about video and other such
things and it's dense and I think it's
relevant and interesting to everything
going on in the world so I want you to
Buckle in today I know that may sound
like I'm overstating it Dave you're
really setting yourself up for failure
here by really telling us this is going
to be a big great show today but that's
how good I feel about this show also
Phoenix was a little worried right
before we started that the show is so
good it's so edgy it's so packed with
truth that government agents could come
in and take us away right after this so
if it's the last show I also want to say
I've enjoyed this thank you for watching
and you know good luck with all that the
theme of the show today is how the left
and the globalists and the Machine The
Matrix whatever you want to call it
their influence which seems like it's
everywhere right it just feels like it
is in every portion of your life no
matter which way you look locking you
down and covet and injecting you and now
coming for gas stoves and they want more
of your money and they want you to eat
bugs and they don't want you to drive
cars all of that stuff
we are going to lay out the case that it
is more of a product of their
infrastructure that they have built a
system that makes it seem that many of
us are convinced of their ideas as
opposed to their ideological persuasion
as opposed to having the right ideas on
their side and those of us that are not
NPCs that are not non-playable
characters those of us with a flicker of
thought those of us who want people to
be free and make choices for themselves
we could actually learn a thing or two
from looking at them and seeing their
tactics and I think there are three
things that we can do
and that's what I'm going to be laying
out in the course of this next hour so
we have to repel their bad ideas right
that's why we try to expose their bad
ideas you have to be able to look at
what they're doing and repel them right
really just say no no no no no no we
ain't going for that [ __ ] we have to
replicate some of their infrastructure
because you have to give the devil his
due they built institutions that then
turned on us whether their education
institutions or scientific medical
institutions
etc etc and then we have to go on the
offense because enough of just reacting
that's what we do we react because most
of us have lives and we have families
and we're doing other stuff and then
they just keep marching because they are
devoted to the endless destruction of
all things good but perhaps it is time
for us to go on offense so that is what
we will be laying out today so let's
start what with what's going on in a
remote Village known as Davos okay this
is where the world economic Forum a
group of unelected Elites from countries
all over the world get together with
about 5 000 armed security guards they
all fly in on their private planes while
they tell you that they're going to be
taking away your modes of travel and
they talk about how they can re-jigger
the world in the image which they like
which unfortunately is often in conflict
with human freedom and flourishing but
let's get a little bit more from what's
going on over at the wef in Davos from
our friends at the daily wire lawmakers
businesses Business Leaders and
academics participating in the world
economic Forum will descend upon the
small ski town of Davos Switzerland this
week to discuss a variety of policy
proposals that entail greater
coordination between government and
corporate actors the organization which
German Economist Klaus Schwab has
chaired for the past five decades is a
leading proponent of stakeholder
capitalism an approach to investing that
says Executives must consider the needs
of communities and other parties in
addition to shareholders the world
economic forum is convening during
January for the first time since the
lockdown-induced recession this year's
conference theme is cooperation in a
fragmented World which involves how we
can tackle the numerous and interlinked
challenges the world is facing and finds
Solutions through public-private
cooperation according to a press release
beyond the more than 1 400 Business
Leaders scheduled to attend the
conference Executives expected to speak
or participate in panel events include
Microsoft CEO sataya Nadella BlackRock
CEO Larry Fink and moderna CEO Stefan
bonsai sell hundreds of world leaders
including German Chancellor Olaf scholes
European Central Bank president
Christine Lagarde Ukrainian first lady
olena zelenska and Canadian Finance
Minister Christian Freeland will also
attend the conference Schwab has
garnered worldwide notoriety for
suggesting that lockdown-induced
recession presents an opportunity for
Elites to create craft a great reset of
the planet's economic and social systems
the three components of the plan are
governments guaranteeing fairer outcomes
in the marketplace channeling
Investments towards equality and
sustainability efforts and using medical
technology to address Health and Social
changes okay so I know that was a lot of
reading there I hope you were paying
attention but basically all of the stuff
that a couple years ago there were some
crazy people on the computer machine
talking about these conspiracy theories
of a group of Elites who get together
every year to figure out how governments
are going to work together against the
needs of the people but they'll do it in
the guise of you know being good to
everybody it all turned out to be true
okay it all turned out to be true that
is what they do they do what you could
argue is a fascistic tactic governments
and corporations working together to
figure out how they can take more from
you and give more to themselves do not
be under the illusion my friends for one
moment that these people care about you
at all they will fly on their private
planes while they tell you you can't be
in your gas car they will eat their
filet mignon their wagyu A5 filet mignon
while they tell you you have to eat bugs
and they do a whole bunch and they are
planning a whole bunch of other weird
stuff we're gonna get to that in the
course of this show but the world
economic conference World economic Forum
conference began in Davos and they
brought out Klaus Schwab if you've seen
cloud Joshua we've talked about him a
bit on the show he's the Emperor
Palpatine of this operation okay this is
shiv Palpatine from planet Naboo people
thought he was a good guy turned out to
be the most evil dude in the Galaxy uh
he opened the conference and he's a
little concerned actually and this is
actually good okay so
bear with me here this is actually
pretty good he is concerned that people
are saying mean things about the people
over in uh Davos take a look propagation
in the fragmented world
at the beginning of this year
we are confronted
with unprecedented and multiple
challenges we need to overcome the most
critical fragmentation
and the most critical fragmentation is
between those who take a constructive
attitude
and sows
who are just bystanders Observers
and even
go into the negative critical and
confrontational attitude
so this is good what's happening right
now because we still have some degree of
a free Internet it's probably less a
degree of a free internet than we all
think and we all know about the
government collusion related to Russia
files and covid and all of those things
but he's opening the conference by
saying kind of hey we're under attack
people don't seem to really like us and
that really is the truth you know I made
a tweet yesterday I took a look at the
world economic forums Twitter account
their Twitter account has
4.3 million followers that that's a
pretty significant number of followers
their average tweet gets about 20 or 30
retweets mathematically I'm not a math
the magician I'm not a statistician but
that's almost impossible 4.3 million
people signed up to watch their stuff
and virtually everybody ignores them
I've got like a million to a million
three followers and all my stuff gets in
the thousands and I'm obviously Shadow
banned right so it's like there's proof
in the pudding they also one of the
things you can do on Twitter this is
little Insider baseball but these things
are important just in the way we
communicate these days you can actually
shut off your comments on Twitter
meaning that if you normally if I tweet
something I put it out there and then
you know I get you know hundreds
sometimes thousands of people responding
to what I say there's a button you can
click or a dial you can slide that
actually shuts off the comments they
shut off the comments on all of their
tweets because every time they tweet
something people were going after them
and saying you're a bunch of Evil Lizard
people and other such factual
information so they are worried that
they are getting criticism they are
worried that there are people who are
not happy with this idea of a one world
government and this is pretty damn good
they are on their heels a little bit but
who else is there and what else are they
talking about well John Kerry is there
and you may remember John Kerry John
Kerry failed presidential candidate and
I would say really a sham of a human who
over the last 10 years or so of his
career has basically taken a private
plane all all over the world
while telling us that again we should
not be on these planes we should barely
be on any planes and we should watch out
for cars were driving and he does this
while making millions and millions of
dollars he also married Teresa Heinz
Kerry so he married into big ketchup did
you guys know that he married into the
big ketchup money okay not Hunt's
Ketchup I'm talking about Heinz how many
ingredients 52 whatever it is 57 okay
that's John Kerry's Cash Cow okay and
I'm pretty sure he's injecting it in his
face also anyway he goes around the
world and he tells governments what they
can do and what they can't do and that
the United States will foot the bill on
climate and all of this stuff but listen
to this speech it's about 40 seconds of
his opening remarks and he really thinks
that he is God that he is God hanging
out with other gods and that they are
here to save the world
and when you stop and think about it
it's pretty extraordinary
that we select group of human beings
because of whatever touched us at some
point in our lives are able to sit in a
room and come together
and actually talk about saving the
planet I mean it's so almost
extraterrestrial to think about quote
saving the planet if you said that to
most people most people they think
you're just a crazy tree-hugging Lefty
liberal you know do-good or whatever
record I do think you're a crazy Lefty
tree hugging do good whatever I could
come up with a couple more adjectives
but do you see these people these
self-righteous
oh moralist buffoons look at us we were
touched by something I'm pretty sure we
know what they're touching but they were
touched by something and that something
gave them extraterrestrial passwords to
sit in a room with other people and talk
about saving the world they're so great
oh I'm busting into my Al Gore accent
already because we got an Al Gore video
coming up so Al Gore you may remember Al
Gore also failed presidential candidate
who has run around and made millions and
millions of dollars making people think
that the sky is falling Al Gore also
gave a talk now you're going to see this
video of Al Gore if you haven't seen Al
Gore lately you're gonna you're gonna
think this is a man wearing an Al Gore
suit but we confirmed this is actually
video of Al Gore uh take a look
enough already enough
and I don't want to get sidetracked onto
what needs to happen but we need to
scale up climate Finance but we need
desperately to scale down anti-climate
Finance
and we are still subsidizing the burning
of fossil fuels globally at a rate 42
times larger than the subsidies for the
shift toward Renewables and EVS
Etc we need new leadership at the World
Bank we need them to scale up the
leverage and vastly increase the amounts
that are are committed and we need to
rein in the anti-climate activities of
the fossil industry oh they need to
reign in those activities of those of us
who want gas stove so do you see how
these things are all connected and yes
that actually is Al Gore
apparently not wearing a fat suit that's
just what's happened to him it looks
like he's filled with jelly okay you'd
think you'd be cutting down on the Eaton
if you really cared about the
environment right you'd think you'd be
doing that Al Gore Al Gore by the way if
you want to talk about grifters and
charlatans please Google this Al Gore
when he left the White House as Bill
Clinton's VP he started a cable channel
called current TV that some of you may
remember it was a complete failure of a
cable channel it was it was going to be
like a a lefty socialist sort of Bernie
Sanders New Media uh Cable News Channel
like to compete with CNN and MSNBC and
fox Etc using all of his connections as
vice president he was able to get on all
the cable channels so he could get on
Comcast you could get on DirecTV et
cetera et cetera that's the hard part of
building a cable channel right because
you have to have all of the connections
so he leveraged his connections as vice
president to get on all the cable
channels he creates a failure of a
network the network never made money the
programming was awful nobody was
watching then you know what he did Al
Gore Google this please Google this he
sold current TV which was worth nothing
except that it had access to the cable
channels it had nothing that anyone was
buying nobody was buying the programming
nobody was buying any of the stuff that
they had created
sold it for 500 million dollars
to Qatar yeah he sold it to Al Jazeera
which is obviously state-sponsored media
from Qatar Qatar if I'm not mistaken is
the number two exporter of
um fossil fuels
how bizarre that Al Gore did that by the
way Glenn Beck this was at the beginning
of the blaze Glenn Beck tried to buy
current TV he wanted to get blaze on all
of those channels Al Gore said no to
Glenn Beck because he's a mean scary
capitalist and sold it to the number two
exporter of fossil fuels Qatar in the
world so Al Gore fat suit jelly Al Gore
is not a good man speaking of not a good
man here is one of the heroes of the
world economic Forum if you've got Klaus
Schwab is Palpatine this guy I would say
is more of uh it's not a Darth Vader
what would he be here this Hariri he
looks maybe sort of a Boba Fett yeah
there's a little bit of a of a bounty
hunter situation with this guy so this
is Yuval Noah harai or Hariri and he is
very interested in the way humans behave
and how we can change how we behave and
how we think and how we learn and
government must be in charge of all of
those things maybe the most important
quality to survive and flourish in the
21st century is to have mental
flexibility
not just to keep learning and changing
again and again also to keep letting go
as virtual reality
improves and you know with all the talk
of the metaverse and so forth that we'll
discuss later on increasingly it's
likely that will be many more activities
shifting from the physical biological
world that we know
into a new reality a virtual reality
which has different physical and
biological laws even the laws of physics
there are different
so whether you want to interact socially
there or maybe you have a job
in virtual reality in the metaverse or
maybe you design you you have a new job
designing fashion designing shirts for
virtual reality because people want to
look good there you need to forget
how physics and light and gravity works
here
we can't do it alone
like place you can't do it alone or
individuals can't do it alone
individuals can't do it alone um it's
too much for an individual to do just by
themselves
uh we'll probably have uh will require
organizations governments to step in to
make sure that people are not left
behind
you know just retraining people we will
have to to see more government support
I really hope you guys were following
that because this is seriously Twisted
evil stuff what he is talking about
there is perhaps an inevitability that
we will all end up in this digital world
in the future that might be the part of
humanity the stage of humanity that
we're at I will grant him that we the
the the entropy of what's going on in
the digital world and the push towards
that is so powerful that he might be
right we all end up there and so what is
there and when we talk about the
metaverse many of you probably saw the
movie Ready Player one it was a great
book and then it was a movie by Steven
Spielberg about maybe 10 years ago or so
you absolutely absolutely should see it
if you have not seen it but this idea
this is what Mark Zuckerberg and the
rest of these technocrats have been
pushing on us that we are going to wear
you know the Oculus you're going to wear
this device over your eyes and you will
live in essence this is idiocracy you
will live in a digital universe
where somehow your body will survive I
mean this is also the Matrix The Matrix
the human body was the battery for the
digital world you still needed the
battery right watch The Matrix if you
haven't seen it again that's when Neo's
wake up is realizing that he's just the
battery humans are just the battery for
the digital thing these guys want us all
to live in the metaverse what they want
is us to be wearing this thing somehow
we'll be fed so the battery will
continue right we'll eat our bug goo or
whatever it is but we will barely live
here
right we will barely live in in the
reality of reality that humans have been
living in for a long time now why would
they want us in the metaverse all the
time and in the metaverse if you watch
Ready Player one or if you just just
think about it in the metaverse you can
be whatever you want you can be a giant
monster you can be a rich athlete you
can be a porn star you could be whatever
you want and you can constantly be
changing and that's why he's saying the
laws of physics don't matter in the
metaverse because they're going to be
able to constantly be rewriting reality
and anything that's imaginable will be
happening there look I'm a Sci-Fi guy
there is something cool about all of
that but the real reason they want you
there is what he said at the end and
that they're going to have to control
you we're gonna have to control we're
gonna have to work with governments to
make sure people are gonna have to make
that shift to this thing what if you
don't want to make the shift to this
thing what if you like your family and
you don't want to dress up like an ogre
in a virtual land right and dance with a
four-eyed robot what you're just old
school
why would they want to push you there
well do you think maybe they'd want to
push you there because they would
basically control every facet of your
mind right they would control what you
spend and when you spend it and oh you
said some bad thing about the wef I
guess we're gonna have to freeze their
bank account do you see how this is all
linked to what's been going on in the
world do I seem like a crazy conspiracy
theorist or are they telling us they are
literally telling us the plan right in
front of ourselves okay we got all that
so you can see it this left-wing
globalist and the reason I call it left
wing is because it's centralized power
right it's top down power I like
bottom-up power right I like on the
ground you make decisions for yourself
and then have loose structures above us
so that you can live freely that would
be better to me they like Central Power
tell you what to do you're gonna have to
live in the metaverse and if you don't
we'll probably call you a white
supremacist and a bunch more so what
else else are they planning because
they're planning all sorts of economic
things they're planning
you know the things that you're gonna
have to strap on your head and a whole
bunch more well obviously a lot of this
is going to be related to medicine and
Pharma I don't know if you remember but
they also put this covet hoax on us over
the last couple years and got people to
do all sorts of crazy things so here is
a video produced by the world economic
Forum uh and then you'll see a professor
talking about it where they're talking
about how mRNA vaccines will give the
ability for them to write a new code for
life this my friends is bananas
[Music]
speaking we're talking about improving
biology and redesigning organisms for
beneficial purposes it's going to allow
us to not just edit genomes but also and
importantly write a new code for Life
we'll have right level permissions we
already started to see some of that this
year covid-19 vaccines they make use of
engineered code in the form of messenger
RNA
[Music]
what's on the horizon are diminished
reality glasses that look very much like
what I'm wearing that would allow you to
remove things from your point of view
from your view whether that's garbage uh
or other people
and dystopia now okay the thing about
being in dystopia if you watch any
dystopian movie is the people don't
realize they're in dystopia till the end
then they have to blow up a whole lot of
stuff I'm talking about this stuff now
so we don't have to blow up a whole
bunch of stuff right uh okay so what
they want to do here and you can now see
because again they're telling us this
was all related to covid get a whole
bunch of people literally hundreds of
millions of people all over the world to
inject themselves with our experimental
mRNA vaccine which then we can use some
of the technology of that to rewrite
their Gene sequencing to to literally
change the genes in people and then what
else can you do oh and then she talked
about diminished reality glasses which
is obviously connected to the to the
metaverse so you're going to put on
these glasses and oh if you don't like
that person you're not going to see them
well I'm pretty sure you're still going
to feel it when they punch you in the
face when you walk right oh you don't
like seeing garbage you're not going to
see garbage this is brave new World read
the book I remember read I read Brave
New World I was in sixth grade did you
ever read a new world yeah I mean uh
it's happening man it's happening right
now so what else are they doing related
to our bodies I always thought it was my
body my choice but no uh here is video
this is from back in September where the
world economic Forum had another
conference uh this is uh Albert borla
he's the Pfizer CEO this guy should
absolutely be in jail he is a criminal
and an evil mfer uh talking about how
we're going to swallow microchips uh
with technology in them and somehow
that's going to be good for I guess his
bottom line even if you make the
greatest drug or the greatest wearable
there's no guarantee that the patient is
going to take the drug wear the device
so how are you thinking about technology
to engage the patient
again maybe I will use an example I
think it's fascinating what's happening
in this field right now I mean FDA
approved the first electronic pill if I
can call it like that so it is a
basically biological chip that it is in
the tablet
and once you take the tablet and
dissolves into your stomach sends a
signal but you took the tablet
so imagine the applications of that
compliance the insurance companies to
know that the medicines that patients
should take they do
oh so we'll just swallow a pill with
some electric stuff in there and that'll
make sure we behave the way we want
because you know you swallow that thing
and uh maybe you can get a boner Maybe
not maybe you need another thing for
that maybe your uh your eyeballs dry up
uh maybe you get the Restless Leg
Syndrome the Jimmy hips
God they're evil but all right let's
just say Dave you're being a little
alarmist oral is a nice man Pfizer is a
good company these people just want to
help us obviously they have a great
track record when it comes to
vaccinating people and some of the other
things they've done I mean show us a
video where what they've done works
because don't be so negative stop being
a negative Nelly
today Pfizer reported its vaccine for
kids 5 to 11 was more than 90 percent
effective in preventing symptomatic
covet in clinical trials overwhelmingly
voted in favor of recommending the
vaccine which Pfizer says is 91
effective at preventing severe infection
he have thoroughly reviewed all of the
available safety
immunogenicity and efficacy Data before
recommending this vaccine for your child
just minutes after the CDC approved the
Pfizer children's vaccine last night
kids were rolling up their sleeves I
would not be concerned because this is
shown now over a considerable period of
time to be a highly effective and safe
vaccine we want to protect the children
for parents of young children unsettling
news new data from New York State shows
the only covet vaccine children 5 to 11
can take made by Pfizer offers almost no
protection against infection the
vaccine's effectiveness in that age
group dropped from 68 percent in
mid-December to just 12 percent by the
end of January just two weeks ago Pfizer
said it was postponing seeking FDA
authorization for a vaccine for kids six
months to four years old after trials
showed it didn't work well now today's
news about the vaccine for 5 to 11 year
olds not being as effective Pfizer says
it's now evaluating a third dose for
children 5 to 11 years old and vaccine
makers are already developing new
formulas ah you see what I did people
that was the old bait and switch you saw
what I did I I thought I was tipping it
off with my rather sarcastic intro to it
I was telling you that he was we were
going to show you a video of him doing
good stuff and it all turned out to be
evil and rates of heart issues and all
of the stuff so why it's not only that
none of these people have been fired
Portland should be should be shamed he
should be hiding somewhere in Argentina
Like A Nazi in 1947 right but instead
he's still in charge of stuff wolenski
fauci these people should be shamed and
never seen in Civil Society again but
instead they are plotting the future
they are plotting their next moves and
speaking of next moves these things just
seem to come
and we don't know what to do that's what
I'm saying we're always reacting to them
right because we're trying to live our
lives and then every day you wake up and
you're like oh my God now boys or girls
now racism is cool again like it just
never stops and and it's hitting
everything so we talked about it related
to medicine and governments and
Technology but the other way that they
leak all of this stuff in and this is
probably the most pernicious way is
through entertainment it's through
culture that's why Politics as Andrew
Breitbart said is Downstream from
culture you capture people's
imaginations first through media and
movies and television and video games
and everything else and then the the
political stuff is just sort of easy to
get into their system because you've
softened them up so you may have seen
this video this is really nuts uh over
the weekend
was Miss Universe okay I don't really
care for these things very much but they
had the Miss Universe Pageant Miss
Universe's new owner is a dude
the only thing is he's a dude who
dresses up like a chick and has boobs
and wears lipstick but the person that
I'm about to show you is Miss Universe's
new owner
and again this is a dude
dressed up as a chick
sort of like a Mrs Doubtfire situation
enjoy the Miss Universe organization
from now on it's gonna be ran by women
owned by a trans woman for all women
for all women I am a robot I am a dude
chick robot I am a woman feminism for
everyone even though I have a wang
lordy lordy lordy but it just keeps
coming and you can see how these things
are all connected right the gender stuff
like it's all just gross what how it is
that dude and then the women we could
have showed you a much more extended
version of it all she's going then the
future is far away man women will be in
charge even though she's not a woman and
then all the women stared up oh my God
that's a woman I guess or something but
let's get to some more examples of the
world economic Forum influencing our
institutions what's happening over in
the global energy sector well we talked
about Al Gore before uh but here's a
wild one here is a Scottish Member of
Parliament talking about how the era of
private car use is over on transport uh
second strategic transport projects
review published just two weeks ago
confirms that the era of catering for
unconstrained growth in private card use
is well and truly over the review
follows the sustainability the
sustainable investment hierarchy which
aims to reduce the need to travel
unsustainably and prioritizes making
best use of enhancing existing
infrastructure before investing in new
capacity
it's worldwide guys it is worldwide it
has infected governments everywhere and
just remember
that guy right there
the people at the world economic Forum
they will never abide by the rules that
they are going to set around you they
will drive in their luxury Vehicles they
will fly in their private planes and
they will make sure you can do no such
thing they will have limits around you
that they will not put around themselves
again this is dystopia I think I watched
one of The Hunger Game movies but isn't
this kind of like a Hunger Game
situation they live one way everyone
else lives another way we're sort of in
that we're sort of in something like
that uh and what's happening right here
so we can move from uh from Scotland we
can move right over here and what's
happening in the United States well it's
just suddenly out of nowhere everyone on
the media started talking about how we
have to get rid of gas stoves and then
what happens because you know the way
the media protects all of the bad ideas
of the globalists on the left then they
sh they put out people like Joe
Scarborough Joe Scarborough Scarborough
who will always take every position on
everything we've shown many videos of
that in the past and what's he mocking
is he mocking the people that are coming
after your gas stove the people who want
to cook the way we've cooked for a long
time and you have a right to use gas and
that these idiots think that they can
somehow make as they don't even know
where electricity comes from it's also
stupid but here's Joe Scarborough
instead of Defending individual rights
instead of defending the autonomy of the
United States and our ability to cook as
we please uh he's upset with the
Republicans who are making a big deal
about it
oh my God oh my God oh my God this is
this is this is an issue that that you
you you you you look and you want to see
how politics gets crazy you get one side
gets like
a small kernel
of something half a kernel and they put
in the ground and they water it water
try to get it to grow and and so this
gas stove thing
you get some bureaucrats saying
something that has no power and then
suddenly
you have Rhonda Sanders so I'm going to
protect your guests everybody talking
about gas stoves gas it's yeah you smug
douche Rhonda said this is going to
protect our gas stoves he's already uh
talked about how we're going to keep
that [ __ ] going right here in Florida
Joe Scarborough is worth 25 million
dollars I I don't begrudge anyone making
money I really do not I don't like when
charlatans and obvious grifters
um make a lot of money but I don't
begrudge him the 25 million and that's
his wife by the way he started banging
his co-host a couple years ago and then
they got married to their credit uh
that's Miko Brzezinski and she's worth
about 20 million so they're worth about
50 million together if you think for one
second that they are going to give up
their gas stove and they are going to
give up their cars or whatever else like
you're an NPC but I know you don't think
that because you're watching this show
but these people you see how they're
aiming the wrong way people want to come
for more of your freedoms they want to
come for more of your stuff and their
corporate he is a corporate hack
his job is to mock the people who will
defend the freedoms that's what it is if
if they're coming for a freedom whether
it's the second amendment the First
Amendment whether they're coming for
your ability to cook out of gas so he
will always mock the people defending
the freedoms but let's continue uh
because all of this stuff now we've
talked about sort of it at an energy
front we've talked about it at a at a
gender front with Miss Universe but of
course we have to talk about it from a
racial front because uh you know racism
is everywhere and we must stop racism
racism is very very bad actually racism
is bad um the thing is that they're the
racist well you know what's going on
over in San Francisco which is a leftist
and I think you could argue globalist it
is you it is a city that is a
centralized
one-party city that has all the power to
a couple people the buffoonish governor
of San Francisco the foolish mayor of
San Francisco and then the clownish
governor of California uh well you know
what's going on in San Francisco besides
all the drugs I know you know about the
drugs besides all the homelessness the
General State of Decay uh the impending
zombie apocalypse and all that I know
you know about all that stuff uh they're
proposing
let's show the headline this is a good
one San Francisco's reparations
committee proposes 5 million dollars to
each black longtime resident and total
debt forgiveness
I would just like to say that I now
identify as a black chick from San
Francisco a long time black chick from
San Francisco okay I am Shaniqua from
San Francisco I've lived in uh what what
part of this town I don't know much
about San Francisco I lived in the uh up
there in the hill there near the near I
live next door to the Full House house
okay uh Shaniqua next no no or I was
Urkel I'm Urkel's aunt
and uh because they lived in San
Francisco too right I think do they live
in San Francisco
you see how stupid this all is
anyway so that's what San Francisco
wants to do a city that is in utter
disrepair a city run by buffoons with
all of the ideas we've been talking
about here and just endless Progressive
nonsense now they want to give five
million dollars how are you going to
feel first off they don't have any money
right California doesn't have any extra
money all of the people that they want
to tax to uh give the money to the
longtime black people that are there the
five million dollars and the debt
forgiveness they've all left I know one
guy there with some cash he has a lot of
cash but he's got to get out soon if
you're watching you know who you are
we'd love to have you here at Florida
okay guys let's shift to the positive
part about all this the left-wing actors
and and these lunatics who are peddling
the world economic Forum agenda they are
really stupid and and Irene I mean that
they're they're stupid and they have
stupid ideas Al Gore is not a smart
person he is a charlatan uh John Kerry
is not a smart person he is a charlatan
these people have somehow attained power
that I grant them
and there there is value in that they
have they have garnered an awful lot of
power by manipulating information so
that stupid people think they're smart
but they're not smart and another guy
that's not smart is the guy running the
show right here the guy who is being
shown the door even though he doesn't
know it of course you know who I'm
talking about Joe Biden uh Joe Biden
yesterday of course was MLK Day Joe
Biden gave a couple speeches and there
were so many ridiculous things that he
said we had to cut a whole bunch of them
because it was just like an endless
calvicade of insanity from Joe Biden
yesterday here he is basically saying
that car insurance companies are racist
give everybody a fair shot that lives
there the same thing by the way if
you're live in one of those
neighborhoods and you have the same
exact car I have in the other
neighborhood you pay more for your
insurance in that size no basis for it
none at all other than you're black and
I'm white
okay so his argument is that Geico
Progressive well Progressive is probably
racist
uh and the rest of these car insurance
companies that when you when they fill
out a form you fill out the form and I
never put my race on anything when I go
to the doctor or anything else it is
seemingly irrelevant when I'm going to
the dermatologist what race I am okay I
don't put any of that stuff but
there his argument is that somehow car
insurance companies they look at black
people and they go you black you're
going to pay more in car insurance it's
not true now what he if he was smart and
Joe Biden is not smart what he might
want to address is that when they're
when companies are looking into
Insurance say house insurance home
insurance right that you're going to
look at the area that a certain group of
people live in and he Biden's I'm going
to try to make Biden's argument for him
his argument would be that there is more
crime in Black communities so insurance
companies then have to charge more for
insurance because they know there's
going to be more home break-ins
something like that now that would make
sense an insurance company they have
people called actuaries and what an
actuary does is check risk whether it's
on home insurance or life insurance Etc
et cetera they have to look at the risk
and then they can say oh this is a very
high risk person or a high risk area we
have to charge them more of a premium so
that in case the house is broken into or
the guy jumps off a cliff because he's a
thrill seeker the we're not getting
screwed when we're doing the payouts
that's how this whole thing works now
Biden could make some argument about
that that because there is more crime
perhaps in certain black communities
that his connection then is it's about
the color of the skin but here's the
flaw in the argument okay and I think I
made his argument way better than he
made it himself the flaw in the argument
is if you want to discuss why perhaps
there is more crime in the inner city
where there are more black people you'd
need only look at the policies of the
Democrats for the past 50 years you only
have to look at the welfare state and
you only have to look at the handouts
and you only have to look at the
intergenerational apartment buildings
that people are stuck in because of
subsidized housing that were all
policies of the Democrats that then
cause people to not go out there and get
the get better jobs and and fight for
their whatever it is that they can get
on this Earth so I know Biden can't make
that argument if you want more on that
argument might I recommend Thomas Seoul
or Larry Elder that would be a pretty
good start
um here's Biden in July of 2021 it's
hard to remember back a year and a half
ago uh basically saying that Facebook
was killing people and the way the
reason I'm linking all of these things
together is to show that these people
are not right and it's not just that
they're not right they have lied all
along and then what happens is they get
everything wrong and then finally
reality catches up to them and then they
have to lie about it so here's Biden
July of 21 Facebook's killing people
because you know Facebook's book is
spreading myth information about the
vaccines
what's your methods of platforms like
Facebook
[Music]
they're killing people
I mean it really look the only pandemic
we have is among the unvaccinated
and that's and they're killing people
all right so to be clear it was never a
pandemic of the unvaccinated we now know
that vaccinated people are getting
coveted at higher rates than
unvaccinated people on top of the fact
that the vaccines don't work you can get
and transmit covid but somehow Facebook
was killing people right so do you see
the way they use fear and utter
incompetence right so I don't know if it
was that he was just trying to scare the
hell out of everybody or he just doesn't
know what the hell he's talking about or
he is also just a stooge of the machine
that's above all of us and what did the
machine want the machine wanted
everybody vaxxed and you know why the
machine wanted everybody backs because
they were testing out that mRNA stuff
which just go back to the beginning of
this video they have all sorts of other
plans for it so that they can edit your
genes and a whole bunch more but how
about a little more proof man we nailed
it today how about a little more proof
that they get everything wrong and then
when reality smacks them in the face
then they start freaking out here is New
York city mayor Eric Adams and you may
remember Eric Adams is the guy who
replaced true communist nutbag Bill de
Blasio who absolutely ruined New York
City the greatest City in the history of
the world okay if you can make it there
you can make it anywhere although now
you just want to get the hell out of
there he took over for him and people
said well you know he is a Democrat but
he's not a crazy lunatic well Eric Adams
then said we are a sanctuary City so all
sorts of people started coming from all
parts of the world they would get
through our poorest border they'd show
up in New York City and they have turned
New York City into a disgusting
crime-infested pot smelling sewage
build crap Factory
I did that with no teleprompter okay
people this is all just coming out of my
brain well then what happens it happens
for long enough all your productive
people they start leaving your city your
city is a dump and then you start
realizing that we can't handle all of
these people in our Sanctuary City and
we don't want them anymore Eric Adams
[Music]
don't deserve this
migrants don't deserve this
and the people who live in the cities
don't deserve this we expect more from
our national leaders to address this
issue in a real way we learned today
with a very informative and that's why
it was important to come here
that there are websites that are
advertising that New York City basically
speaks a paid with gold that there's
automatic employment that you're
automatically going to be living in in
hotel there's a conversation among those
who are Asylum and uh my silencies and
migrants who are getting given the false
impression that if you come to New York
City everything is fine
Eric Eric
you were the one that called for New
York City to be a sanctuary City you
were the one that said hey come here you
are the one that actually tried to get
some of the illegal immigrants to vote
in elections which would have been
doubly illegal
uh you also support the president of the
United States and the Democrat Party who
are in charge of the Border they're the
ones in charge right now but what
happens all of your stupid Lefty ideas
come to your door all of the good people
leave your city your city crumbles and
now it's a problem now it is a problem
so how is it guys that they are able to
get everything wrong always
cause a whole bunch of us to constantly
have to react to their BS and then only
when it fully comes to their doorstep
like it's happening to Eric Adams now
might he wake up and go oh it is a
problem we should have a border and
being a sanctuary City actually makes no
sense and the Lefty dingbats in Martha's
Vineyard who are all for no human is
illegal but when three people or 30
people show up on Martha's Vineyard help
us help us we're not a Border Town we
don't have that kind of infrastructure
well you know what it's because of the
idea infrastructure basically that these
clowns have bought because they have the
infrastructure they really do
so let's talk about that just a bit uh
Matt Gates Congressman Matt Gates was on
Tim Poole's podcast a couple days ago
and he talked a little bit about why the
machine seems to churn out so many bad
people why is it that people come from
whatever District they come from from
all over the country they come to DC and
why does everything always seem worse
after why do these people say one thing
on the way in and then once they get
here seem to operate a completely
different way he says a lot of it has to
do with Barack Obama and how the state
and the Deep State just grew under Obama
take a look and it really started with a
lot of the Obama people like do you say
what you will about Obama the guy was
good at vertically integrating Personnel
in a lot of these agencies where where
the bureaucracy would bend to their will
like if there's a fair critique of
trumpets that you know he was this great
Visionary but oftentimes the people that
were two three four layers down were
working against him and he didn't roll
into the presidency with this terrific
Rolodex of people that could go and
operate at that level whereas you know
Schiff Obama like these these people
were good at getting people in place to
drive action and we should learn from
that
that's super interesting so here you
have a full-on trump Guy saying You
Gotta Give Obama credit I don't like
what he did but he was able to do it he
staffed this machine with all of the
people who are going to get his stuff
done right they were going to accomplish
his goals and then he's also critiquing
his guy right he's he's As Trump As
Trump can be right like he's Trump town
but he's saying Trump actually he had
the right ideas but he did not know how
to do that that is a legit criticism
it's a criticism that other people have
levied as well but it's interesting
hearing it from a full-on trump guy
Gates continued and he started talking
about how the infrastructure itself of
DC it advances the people the actors who
share that same left-wing ideology that
same centralization of power uh well
take a look
now
or now or in a minute if you're part of
the
prevailing way of thinking the National
Security State the neoconservative
worldview there's an entire
infrastructure there to like build out
your career there are endowed
professional professorships there are
think tanks that are ready to give you
six figure jobs there's a like career
progression of jobs on the hill but if
you think differently you're kind of
hunted in a lot you know you're hunted
canceled they do everything to
compromise you and if that doesn't work
they try to destroy you I want to blow
your mind right now so Matt Gates is
considered by mainstream he is
considered far right right he's
considered far right
do you remember my interview way back
when we've played this clip a couple
times and he's talked about it in many
other interviews my interview from a
couple years ago with Tom the soul
Thomas Soul talked about how he was a
Marxist and a socialist and when he got
his first government job right out of
school he went in and he started looking
at the government programs and saying
boy you know we're looking at these
government programs we're looking at the
money we put into these things and we're
looking at the output and it turns out
these government programs don't work and
he brought that information this is a
very famous story he brought that
information to the higher-ups at the
government and he said guys you know we
put all these money into these
communities and we're not helping
anybody actually uh it's quite the
reverse
and they basically said uh shut up
that's pretty much what they said and
that was one of as Thomas Soul describes
himself his key moments to waking up to
what the government actually is what the
federal government actually is it does
not want to solve problems it wants to
keep expanding like a cancer it wants to
keep replicating and continuing and
going and going and going so it's
interesting that Gates and soul are
actually hitting on the same thing that
this machine is not in the business of
fixing things uh it is in the business
of making sure that it protects itself
he continued to talk about it here I
sort of referenced this before about
what happens to these guys you know
because this happens every now and again
every couple of years you'll find some
like great Congressman kind of saying
all the right things usually somewhere
in the middle of the country but then
they get to DC and it seems like they
can't get anything done and Gates argues
there's actually a technical
infrastructure reason related to that I
think like the most corrupt
like
foray into this is like freshman
orientation because like you show up
here and I mean you know imagine showing
up from Northwest Arkansas from like you
know Southern Mississippi and you see
the architecture of DC they take you out
to like the finest steakhouse the best
wine you've ever had and co-located at
your table are the lobbyists for the
major special interests for the
Committees that you're interested that
you want to serve on so like I get here
and they're like oh Gates you want to be
on the armed services committee have you
met these defense contractors these are
the key lobbyists that round up the
defense money and they put you with them
from the very beginning and you sort of
get the joke that if you give your vote
card to the leadership and your calendar
to the lobby Corps you just kind of get
enveloped into a system that's there to
nurture you and protect you and keep you
out of Harm's Way and all it costs you
is your own belief set and I don't think
that's compromised so much as selling
out now you know that so that is like
step one and that catches a whole lot of
the people who get here and then beyond
that if you kind of resist that system
then they do try to extort you engage in
anything they can do to compromise you
cancel you find some joke that you liked
on Instagram years ago that like doesn't
fit with the mores of this time find
some email that you are on link to
forward chain of it's like some basis to
say that you're a white supremacist
kind of sounds right doesn't it right
like that should be thought of as or
mainstream would spin it that that's
conspiracy stuff
but it kind of seems right
you know even if you were to look at the
way that the mainstream media treats
Matt Gates that he's some kind of white
supremacist and he's some kind of
insurrectionist and all of that stuff
um but actually the system is in place
for you to get to DC and be having
dinner at Peter Peter Luger's in
Brooklyn but have dinner at Morton's
Steakhouse
you know getting a real nice filet on
the bone with the lobbyist that you're
supposed to be ignoring actually if you
cared about the interests of the people
so this is how the system works but you
might be saying Dave this couldn't be
happening for so long right I mean this
isn't something that the government's
been doing for quite some time well we
went into the archives and yesterday was
MLK day and uh Martin Luther King pretty
good dude right I'd say pretty good
track record liked by a lot of people
did you know that it is a fact that the
FBI admitted to lying about MLK being a
communist so that they could spy on him
did you know that it's true videotape
and their activity to go after Dr King
didn't even cease when he died
because as Congress began to consider
the question of whether or not Dr King's
birthday should be named in Maine made
made a national holiday
the bureau developed plans to call in
Friendly congressmen for off the Record
briefings concerning King in the hopes
that those congressmen could keep any
such bill from being reported out of
committee
a report was written for the director by
his chief intelligence officer reporting
that the Communist Party
in fact for 40 years had been trying to
control the Negro movement and that had
always failed
and that its efforts in connection with
the March on Washington were
infinitesimal
this was not accepted by the director of
the FBI
he found that thinking wrong
unacceptable and said that it must be
changed and it was changed and then we
find paper coming in in which the lower
level people in the FBI apologize for
having misunderstood matters and on they
go with this effort to discredit and
start they do the bugs
on Dr King
well that's pretty interesting that the
FBI was involved in discrediting the
greatest civil rights leader of our time
right uh if you're wondering the church
committee so that was part of the church
Committee hearing and they were showing
that on C-Span as part of the 45th uh
sorry it was the 40th anniversary of the
church committee the church committee
was a U.S Senate Select Committee in
1975 that investigated abuses by the CIA
the National Security Agency the Federal
Bureau of Investigation the FBI and the
IRS doesn't it kind of seem like we
could use another church committee right
now right like imagine if the new
Congressional Republicans who as I've
been saying like they're showing some
balls right now imagine if they come in
and said hey what has happened here
related to kovid what has happened here
related to this Russia hoax what has
happened here related to trampling on
the First Amendment because of the
collusion between big Tech and
government what has happened here
between potentially uh FBI and CIA
involvement in January six like there's
so much stuff and the reason that we
probably need something like the church
committee right now is until someone
is fired for some of this until the
executives stop getting
bigger bonuses and golden parachutes and
moving on up and the people who screwed
over everybody
they should not be then at the world
economic Forum to figure out what the
future things they can screw us up on so
we could use something like the church
committee these days let's just show you
a little bit more on this because this
is wild did you know that the FBI
actually tried to get Martin Luther King
Jr to kill himself yes they did it's
fact
now the bureau went so far as to mail
Anonymous letters to Dr King and his
wife
which were mailed shortly before he was
awarded the Nobel Peace Prize
and finishes with this
suggestion
King there is only one thing left for
you to do you know what it is you have
just 34 days in which to do it this
exact number has been selected for a
specific reason it has definite
practical significance it was 34 days
before the award you are done
uh if I can interrupt that was taken by
Dr King to mean a suggestion for suicide
was it not that's our understanding the
document which was found is a draft of
the letter which was the anonymous
letter which was actually sent is there
any dispute that the letter did in fact
come from the FBI uh we've heard no
dispute of that
so the FBI wrote an anonymous letter to
Martin Luther King to scare him into
committing suicide
we had a commission to deal with some of
those things and maybe I'm actually I'm
curious that we need to do a show
Phoenix let's do a show like a real show
on the church commission and all of the
Fallout post that it would be really
fascinating to know but do you see what
I'm trying to show you here that there
are times when when things get exposed
and things hopefully change a little bit
maybe they didn't change enough and that
led us to this where we're at 40 some
odd years later but there are moments
when good people get involved and one of
the things that I am bullish on that I
am hopeful for is that the Republicans
have this little sliver to be more
transparent to look into the right
things they're looking into China
collusion they're looking into big Tech
collusion these things are happening
right now maybe they will fail us but
but maybe there's a chance but the only
reason they'll they'll do it is if we
force them to do it if we if we show
them that hey if you guys act bravely
and do the right thing we'll support you
the best example of that is Ron DeSantis
in Florida obviously he started doing
the right thing people started backing
him up he wins by the craziest Landslide
now has super majorities here in Florida
and Florida is free and flourishing but
I think we can export that so now I want
to show you this is Matt Gates one more
time talking on CNN uh with uh what's
smerconish's first name I forgot with
this merconish guy about why they should
have more cameras in Congress that we
should have more transparency and by the
way as we played a video last week Kevin
McCarthy the new leader of the house has
said that they are going to open up
they are going to open up the halls of
Congress so that people can actually
watch the debates so there are good
things happening take a look without
C-SPAN cameras we would not have seen
you nearly attacked by Mike Rogers do
you think that incident is an example of
why some of your colleagues they don't
want full camera access
no I think that the reason people have
opposed our effort to democratize
viewing of the house floors because in
many of the debates no one's present and
they want to maintain the fiction that
that's actual legislating and whenever
there's sharp disagreement or Discord or
fiery debate on the floor or in
committee the camera always catches
those moments but there are also moments
of great interpersonal warmth and
collaboration and the forming of
alliances that you might not normally
see whether it's myself talking to ilhan
Omar about War Powers or pramila jayapal
about big Tech regulation or discussing
floor strategy with AOC I think the
American people would be able to
humanize Congress more if they saw more
of our human interactions and not just
the theater that's on display during
much of the debate
right so good things happening here and
again this is exactly what Kevin
McCarthy has said he is going to do
actually one of the members in our
locals Community said why don't we as a
community take a trip to DC and we'll go
we'll go to a congressional hearing
together and then we'll go to lunch and
a whole bunch more so we are absolutely
going to do that and I'll reach out to
some of these guys maybe we can get a
sit down a few minutes a cup of coffee
with McCarthy or Gates or any of these
people and let's have the people start
engaging the politicians again instead
of doing what they've been doing which
was ramped up severely by covid where
they don't even have to show up in DC
they can just call in or text in their
Vote or whatever it might be so okay
let's get to a little bit more on the
action part so part of the action is
having a bit of transparency having
people actually see what's going on
there that would be pretty good
um another thing that we could do is
actually have some consequences for the
people that got us into all of this
trouble related to all of these things
that we've talked about related you know
kovid Russia big attack all of the stuff
Robert Malone I've talked a bit about
him a bunch we're interviewing him this
week right I think or next week next
week uh who is the you know the inventor
of mRNA technology owns more patents on
mRNA technology than anybody uh he's
become very outspoken related to all
this about how we have to stop these
people uh here he is talking about what
we should do when it comes to World
economic Forum type leaders from a
belief system that says that nation
state is an obsolete idea and we have to
have a one world government that is
basically a fusion of the interests of
Corporations and politics global
politics and we got to start by finding
out who they are voting them out of
office making sure they are not part of
our governments two notable characters
here in the United States are Governors
Inslee and Newsome okay we've got to out
these people we've got to force them to
account for whether or not they're
Americans or are they globalists and if
they're global they gotta get out we
gotta get rid of them we got to take
back ownership of our country if you
believe in the Constitution if you
believe in the principles of free speech
and personal autonomy medical autonomy
and autonomy at every level other level
it's time to fight you know or your
children are going to live in basically
a technofascism for the rest of their
natural lives
okay you got to understand that is the
guy who invented the MRNA technology
that the wef is now
telling us they want to use to literally
change your Gene sequencing and do a
whole bunch of other crazy stuff but
what does he say the answers are the
answers are that we should care about
the nation state we shouldn't care about
One World Government above all of us
right one ring to rule the world we
should care about the the validity of
the United States of America as an
entity that that can govern itself now
we don't have the right people in charge
right now but that was the idea and I
think we can get back to it and by the
way the people in France can govern
themselves as they wish and the people
in Japan can govern themselves as they
see wish he also talks of course about
individual autonomy and medical autonomy
and everything else so what really is he
pushing against well let's flash back to
the world economic Forum this is in
2018. uh here is Klaus Schwab discussing
their globalist agenda uh and then we're
going to flash to you may remember a
certain orange man who actually is
defending the United States in a way
that these people Don don't like very
much
[Music]
so today we need to strike
it's the right balance
between so necessary
rebuilding of national social contacts
and at the same time
strengthening our multilateral system to
I'm here today to represent the
interests of the American people the
world is witnessing the Resurgence of a
strong and prosperous America I'm here
to deliver a simple message there has
never been a better time to hire to
build to invest and to grow in the
United States
regulation is stealth taxation
the U.S like many other countries
unelected bureaucrats I mean we have
believe me we have them all over the
place and they've imposed crushing an
anti-business and anti-worker
regulations on our citizens with no vote
no legislative debate and no real
accountability
in America those days are over as
president the United States I will
always protect the interests of our
country our companies
and our workers
you really know that's that's 2018
middle of Trump's presidency Schwab
talks about the multilateral system what
he means is that the world government
should all be coordinating together and
it's his buddies who should all come up
with the ideas that everybody should
abide by and then Trump gets on the same
freaking stage with him and says I am
here for the American people and America
is going to lead again now it's
unfortunate because Trump a president
anymore and this mentally muddled
buffoon that we've got in charge
obviously does not care about America
first or even America second or third
I'm not sure what he cares about
something about his Corvette I guess
mainly but the ideas that Donald Trump
talked about right there and that he
went to the world economic Forum to push
back against literally everyone there
not the most fun thing to do probably
you know you walk into a giant
conference and everyone there hates you
because they know you're the one guy
who's going to stand up for his country
but you know what Trump did that and
although the postmortem on Trump is
obviously he lost the last election and
who knows what will happen and after
that and or subsequently who knows what
will happen going forward the ideas that
he talked about about individual
sovereignty and people controlling their
own borders and everything else that
actually started getting exported you
may remember this video from a couple
months ago this is newly elected Italian
Prime Minister Georgia Maloney giving an
incredible acceptance speech when she
was voted in as prime minister take a
look
foreign
perfect
that's the spirit that's the spirit
she as the Prime Minister the incoming
now prime minister of Italy she is
allowed to decide what's right for the
people of Italy and it has nothing to do
with what Klaus Schwab and his friends
want okay that she cares about God and
family and Country and how she defines
herself they're always talking about how
they can Define you
what she's talking about there is how
you can Define you I think it's what
we're talking about here pretty good she
continued just a little bit more talking
about nationalism and defending
individual freedom foreign
foreign
grazia indeed that is the spirit that we
need she knows why she's there and by
the way when uh she got elected you may
remember the headlines we showed a whole
bunch of them here she's the fascist the
far right has come to Italy does that
seem kind of familiar the type of stuff
they used to say about Donald Trump for
defending his country for defending the
American way of life for defending
ultimately the individual the irony of
course is that Donald Trump and Maloney
right there defending the idea of the
individual you're not when you truly
defend the individual you not only
defend the individual in your country
you defend the rights of individuals in
other countries these people love the
collective they love state power or
corporate power or just power power they
love that and they love the collective
because then no one's individuality
matters and that is what they are
attacking more than anything else but
guys were about to wrap this thing up
this is officially our longest show ever
I'm kind of in the mood for Italian for
lunch after that
maybe we'll do a little pesto pasta
something
um how do we know it's working well
because I'm going to flash you back to
where we were 70 minutes ago Klaus
Schwab opened the world economic Forum
sweating
he is nervous because people are pushing
back these people do not
um they do not feel that people like
them because people do not like them
because for as long as we have a voice
as long as I have a voice and you have a
voice and we have some semblance of a
free internet we can expose them we can
talk about what they're trying to do we
can vote in better people we can live in
better communities and all of that good
stuff and Klaus Schwab's worried about
that so here's just a portion of him
saying that right from the beginning
that we played we need to overcome the
most critical fragmentation
and the most critical fragmentation is
between those who take a constructive
attitude
and those
who are just bystanders Observers
and even
go into the negative critical and
confrontational attitude
yeah dude when it comes to you I go into
the negative and the critical attitude I
don't like you I am never going to live
under you nobody watching this is gonna
we're gonna fight into the end
ladies and gentlemen this is our longest
show in the history of the Reuben report
I think we did a fine job do we have
gold stickers somewhere I'm gonna pin a
gold sticker on everybody here today if
you have not subscribed please do at
rumble.com Ruben report we are going to
do a live post game show which we're
doing every day right now at
reubenreport.locals.com that's where I
unbutton the jacket I relax people ask
questions comment if I made any mistakes
we do some live Corrections whole bunch
more uh we're going to do that in
just a moment we got a cold close oh
this cold closed we I wanted to put this
into the show we could have I thought it
was a little gratuitous because we were
doing heavy lifting during the show
today but just watch watch this I
normally don't tease the cold clothes so
Joe Biden he's doing the the MLK Day
stuff yesterday and he sings Happy
Birthday to I think it's uh MLK's like
great granddaughter or something like
that and uh yeah he forgets her name
okay see ya but congratulations today
the honorees uh including your wife
uh who I understand uh his birthday
today
well look my wife has a rule in her
family
when somebody's birthday sing happy
birthday you ready happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear Valley
happy birthday to you
well
it's hell Turner 30 but
[Music]
thank you